what is up everybody you guys are in for
a treat okay I'm not wearing a mask
anymore
it hurt my ears it really did hurt my
ears my ears were sore after the first
livestream much respect out to all the
doctors and nurses who are taking care
of us now because they're wearing these
things 24 hours a day I now understand I
kind of configure it I can imagine it
all the bruises around the ears than
their noses from wearing the masks all
day but I can't do it I'm gonna risk
getting sick for you guys this way we do
it here today we're gonna be talking to
Magda Lopez and I'm just excited because
he's gonna show us a little bit of his
creative process and ah okay so some
things I dug up he's born in Havana Cuba
he immigrated to United States at 15 and
he began this poster day series for 365
days and his social media blew up he was
telling us that he went from 400
followers to 20,000 in a very short
period of time so I want to kind of get
into his mindset what why he did that
what was the trigger and all that kind
of stuff you've seen his images before
have you been on Instagram you've seen
it you've seen it elsewhere in the real
world because that he was featured in
The New York Times cosmopolitan
entrepreneur Awards and he's also had
clients such as you know Apple Nike
Absolut Vodka there was a little story
there before we rolled on air here so
we'll we may dip into a little bit MTV
and Warner Brothers
he's also Adobe design mentor if you
haven't seen it he's also he did three I
think three episode series with Adobe
and you definitely want to check that
out but you don't have to just yet and
he's based out of Dallas Texas recently
moved but a little crazy in this middle
of this pandemic but he moved so bare
with us in case anything weird happens
okay here's some of his amazing work
you've seen these posters before they
kind of are kind of pop surrealism
really brilliant colors super saturated
gradients and then these kinds of kind
of weird collages that he'll assemble
together cutting things apart
not necessarily dark but it's just
there's something really cool a little
bit unsettling about his images who am I
talking about talking about Magda Lopez
if you guys want to check them out go to
mag daeul opcom you can follow mirror
we're on social media mag deal lop lop
for Lopez okay so let's get into it mag
deal welcome to the show
having me man I've been get fun for a
while and you know I'm really thankful
to be here with the team I'm really
excited to have you now a little while
ago I sent out an invite and I never
know if somebody's gonna respond because
I follow you and you're like yeah let's
do it but I think we set that date so
long ago it's like now it's creeped up
and we've been talking black what are we
to do on the show today
now I've seen you do this before I've
seen you do a composition from start to
finish and I'd love to see you do that
again if you don't mind yeah we're gonna
do that all right I'm super excited okay
and maybe we can tell little stories
here and they're kind of your ascent
into your career your background your
beliefs all that kind of stuff while
you're working so what do you have in
store for us I love it man I really
don't have anything paper I just thought
we jump on it let's do it you can follow
along yeah and now we can you can even
pick an image together and then go for
really wow yeah that means you're really
really confident because if you have
nothing prepared and you're ready to go
that tells you the guys with doing this
for some time he's ready to go he knows
his system and his know he knows his
process or maybe I'd be moving for the
last two weeks how did you move in
middle all this stuff well I was already
looking for a house so we are about to
close already so it wasn't like I wanna
do it now is just you know we so we had
to close and I thought it was gonna get
canceled but it we happen so I'm happy
to be here you know yeah and you seem
like the most optimistic upbeat guy ever
and I noticed four posters to hanging
right behind your head there are those
posters available for purchase the are I
think I have them on society6 mm-hmm
if I'm not mistaking yeah you can check
it out cited six slash might be a Lopez
I think it is or you can go to my site
and click on shop mmm do you print them
out or the society6 printer man for fill
them for you they do everything you see
in the file nice okay so we'll check
that out we'll include the links in the
description below guys make sure you
check that out after the show all right
let's get into the work so what do you
got on your screen right now let's do it
so do I share my screen or yeah share
your screen okay
yeah careful there's nothing weird in
the background right yeah there's
nothing we are everything is safe
basically you know I have I have the
normal thing that I usually have yes the
title of my poster and you know number
of and a few information here there and
I was already in Adobe stock looking for
images that we could use yeah and I
usually like to use a if we go to
Instagram if I know how to spell we got
an Instagram real quick you can see most
of my posters have these can look to it
yeah so I take a lot of time picking my
images because I wanted to have these I
don't know I don't know how to call it
it's like a nostalgic kind of like ya
know it's not very happy also it's not
at this kind of like in the middle so
you know I you should that and sometimes
I have holsters like this and if we have
time we can make another one you know we
can make one with the face and then jump
and do something more modern okay
a lot of people like doing that as well
okay so yeah so will we look for a real
look for a portrait and we'll see and
what are you looking for when you're
scanning so many images man I'm looking
for something that just you know has
that look that I want and it also gives
me a little bit of room to be creative
within the image you know something that
maybe I can add some color to it maybe
split maybe two different planes when
the hand is fraught kind of in front of
the face and I can play with that as
well unsplash is a great place for that
as well so if you go to unsplash.com and
they have a lot of portraits of people
they do that you can that you can pick
from these are all great actually you
know what I liked some of the ones that
I was looking at before we got on the on
the call so if I look at my library I
can probably see some of the ones that I
had here and we can just pick one
together yeah you see like this ones
that I that I have over here the guys
kind of has his hand in front of the
body I say there's a lot of things you
can do there
do something in the background of that
so you know we can do this one yeah yeah
let's pick this one and drop it in there
and you know feel free to like you know
ask me any questions to talk about any
subject well okay nice
yeah I'll be monitoring the comments in
case you guys want to ask my ideal
question drop them in the comments
section I don't know where I'm pointing
it's one of these directions just drop
them somewhere and I'll read it with it
along with the team just so you guys
know market owner also helping me out in
this broadcast I think mark might be
dipping soon okay that's fine yep we'll
still get to your questions so throw
them out there yeah we'll get to I'll
read them love it so it seems like you
like images of people that are like a
3/4 profile versus straight on profile
or headshot right like straight on like
a little dynamic angle yeah I like that
because I mean it kind of gives you a
better let a more creative thing to play
with you know if you if you go to stray
or whatever you sometimes don't have the
the room to to play it's less artistic
and this image is not artistic at all if
you can see you know I'm envisioning for
it to get darker around the face and all
of that so I think with doing that we
might be able to make it a lot darker
and a lot more you know artistic okay so
you know basically I first thing I do is
like what everybody would do just cut
the photo cut the subject from the from
the photo and Adobe just came up with a
really cool tool cord called the subject
selection - uh-huh
and if you click here on select subject
it just does it for you and you know and
you can see it right there it's like
pretty well selected all around and then
there's a you know a few problem areas
like the hair up here and for that we're
just gonna click on select a mask and
I'm gonna wall a bit on the hair okay
you can see how it just big yeah so I
was telling you Chris I you know I
started working
I started learning Photoshop when I was
13 and I was just having fun with it
my dad had a null computer and I managed
to get a copy of Photoshop and I was
just playing with it and recreating
everything that I would see around me so
basically I don't have any I didn't go
to school because I got my first job
when I was 15
doing graphic design when I moved to the
States but I don't get a job at 15 doing
graphic design that's the job that
everybody wants to have that's watching
this channel and some are still working
on that how did you do that at 15 well I
started when I was 13 so I had a at
least two years of just doing design
every day like I'm signing every day I'm
a house just what I would do said I
would take my dad's books and I would
recreate what they had on them so what
the covers I would recreate him and in
Cuba there's no internet so I couldn't I
couldn't go online and you speak images
so what I would do is that I would take
my own photos we with a camera and then
dump it in the computer and then go from
there you know and there were so many
challenges because sometimes I remember
this one book had all these dots in
front of it and I couldn't figure it out
how to make those dots you know to have
the right distance which is something so
dumb right now but I couldn't figure it
out you know so what I came up with was
to do text and do a bunch of like
pierre-pierre period until I filled up
the whole book and you know like coming
up with solutions like that helped me to
help me to like be super creative a
sense of like you know not having the
answers and having to use chase all of
that by myself
gave me a lot of creativity so I was I
was doing a lot of designs by at that
point so when I moved to the States
I knew my you know my family goes into
the music world and you you know people
that had studios and stuff and a friend
had a music studio and I went over to
him and I was like hey man this is stuff
that I've done you know my you know my
family do you have you know job I know
you're looking for somebody that makes
covers for artists
he was like yeah man I you know
love what you do and basically I started
working there as a part-time I would get
out of school and go there and that was
kind of like a good training for me to
like experience some real-world clients
and disappointment and people pushing
back yeah making things bigger and which
is super essential I feel like - if
you're starting as a designer in your
career you want to have those problems
you want to have people telling you we
don't like the you gotta bei don't make
it that way because that first it makes
you be creative you know yeah and also
it helps you to own or people use
because they hear negative feedback they
just do whatever they they're asked and
they don't put any personal effort into
it and and something that I learned is
that I didn't want to put out that thing
out there if I didn't like it myself
right so I would own their comments and
I would own my work enough to like fight
for it to be amazing but I still do what
they wanted to do and that's conflict
right there and and design and
everything that's creative is conflict
and it's solving problems and you know
that helped me at a really young age to
do that then I moved to Texas when I was
17 and yes sir sorry hey y'all Texas in
the house yes I moved to Texas on 17 and
then here in Texas like same thing like
I started working for my ministry and
they're doing a lot of graphic designs
and I would get a lot of feedback and a
lot of pushback from people that didn't
understand you know older people and
that's all the stuff is so good and you
know I feel like in during that time it
was such a pain I think it was such a
drag to like have to hear these people
telling you change these do these and
you think you know I know better blah
blah blah but at the same time it's what
you need to hear that age I feel like
yeah that's what pushes you to be good
you guys you guys see my screen yeah
yeah we see it okay so I got this image
pretty pretty much cleaned up you can
see I have a layer here with the image
and then have a mask on it and what I
did is that I
drew on top of it this is dark with a
brush I just drew on top of the hair to
hide some of the white around the hair
that's basically everything that's
happened so far okay I just want to
update you guys yeah you cutting around
and what I'm doing yeah there it is
so it's pretty much cut out and then
yeah right now I have this background
that I already had on it when these
cameras but I'm gonna change it
obviously I had it from the previous
poster the one that I posted today but
I'm gonna change the background to
something different I think we should go
with something this burger goes really
well with him too though but I'll do
something different and for gradient I
usually people ask me what's the secret
for the gradients and you know I just go
for it you just use paint with a brush
one on top of the other giving it like a
cool look you know whatever you think
looks good just keep applying colors to
it mm-hmm
and then probably at the end of
desaturate it a little bit or like
change it a little bit mm-hmm but that's
basically what I'm doing right now
yeah so no big secret they're just paint
colors that you like I just say color
that you like yeah yeah um everything
with my work is I feel like it's this
way like there's no big cigarettes or
anything I just I just go for it and and
obviously it's not I'm not I don't want
to be like oh this is easy use you know
you do it what I mean is that if you do
it enough times and then you know what
you want to do and you know how to do it
because you've done the salt so much
yeah and it's kind of like a second
second nature so it's not it's not that
is super easy is that it's super simple
you know mm it just takes time and it
takes effort to to get to the point
where you know what you want to do
before you even start doing it quick
question for you what resolution are you
working at here working let me see
because I I use different resolutions
I'm working at 12 by 17 inches 300 dpi
mm-hmm that's 3,800 by 5100 and that's a
pretty good size if you want to
rent you can go bigger if you want but
this image is already about this size
mm-hmm so even if you make it bigger if
you're not on the vector ice or anything
you might as well stay within the kind
of range of the image and then you can
scale this up a little bit more because
it's 300 dpi yeah I'm working on RGB
mm-hmm and I talked about a secret
before how to always get this right for
RGB and CMYK which is you know when
you're picking your colors and your
dragon this if you get this letter
warning over here and if you can see it
on the screen if you get a warning that
means that it's not gonna print well so
you want to move it to the closest point
where you don't get the warning mm or
you can click on it and it moves it for
you I see yeah so that's a good tip
where people don't want to work and CMYK
and RGB the same thing yeah so um I
don't remember where we were talking
about but I think we're talking about
gradients before and you just like the
simple things are not necessary easy but
that's the way you do it yeah yeah
they're not necessarily like something
you know like that you would think oh
it's easy you know easy for you to say
because you do it so fast whatever but
that's not what I mean what I mean is
that it's easy in the sense of like you
know you do it enough times you learn
what you want to do you learn how to do
it you know and and you go for it hey
Jonah yeah you speak Spanish right
Paquito this is a bilingual show so
check the chat and the Sebastian is
asking a question in Spanish I'm not
gonna actually try to pronounce it so
will you check that out yes
okay keep going back deal yeah so yeah
that's basically you know what if we
feel free to stop me whenever you have a
question about what I'm doing okay but
you know that's story-wise that I keep
going my story and design you know how I
started designing they want to move to
Texas sighs you know I worked in this
place for or about five years to and and
this place man I had to do everything I
had to do video and I had to do graphics
and I had to do all kinds of things so
that prepared me to you to not only be a
good designer in the sense of like hi
to do a lot of work pretty quickly but
also leading other people and if your
goal is not only to be a designer but to
probably have your own studio and
leading all the creatives you need to
learn all of the creative stuff what it
takes for people to do what they do
median wise and design and printing and
all of that so you know you should also
chase that I believe you just chase
something that puts you in the spot
where you feel uncomfortable and you you
should be uncomfortable with you should
be comfortable with being uncomfortable
you should push for that you should
chase that and you know it's hard we
live in the world of comfort you know
the us everything that we that we chase
is comfort and you know the bigger house
and the better cars and the better jobs
and it's hard to to to kind of chase
that you know but if you do especially
in career wise you will definitely
improve really quickly and really you
know in in the good way tell me what
you're doing right now you're cutting
out his arm with the pen tool I'm
coating on his arm oh my idea is to cut
out the arm and then these these these
grading that I had on top of him I'm
gonna have the arm not being affected by
the grading so it's gonna look like it's
behind them a little bit I say yeah so
you say kinda had a mask to do some
color correction on image yes so
basically yeah I'm basically cutting I
like cutting with the pencil because
it's super precise yeah
and getting are we here in these really
dark areas like the computer doesn't
know what's going on right so you know
the pen a great tool to do this and I
did a lot of decently and that Adobe
show that you mentioned and I explained
a lot of it you know how to how to get
better at the pencil and this basically
practice you know and the cool thing
about the pencil is that is really good
with also with vector so if you jump
into Adobe Illustrator is also super
useful for that okay so Sebastian has
what part of your visual reality in Cuba
have you applied into your actual work
my visual reality
well Cuba Cuba is a really colorful
place and you know people are really
color else so I think that's basically
that's an influence that I have from my
country mm-hmm
in that sense also all the experiences
that I've lived in a country like Cuba
Cuba is is a crazy country like if you
think about it there is so much going on
there is so much that you have to be
creative just naturally because you
don't have anything any of the basic
needs that you would have anywhere else
so you have to be cry some you know my
parents being creative all the time to
provide for us and I saw I was creating
myself to quote-unquote survive a little
bit you know the situation in a country
like that so I think everything I do is
influenced by that fight by that you
know by my my roots and what I came from
and all the experiences that I've lived
you know helped me create what I create
what I do
mm-hmm in that sense yeah so I think I
don't know if that that's what you meant
your question Sebastian but it not only
affect you answer in Spanish yes there
you go hey we have yeah we have fellow
guests on our show right now Roy
Cranston's in the house he's asking Matt
do you feel like these posters an
example of art or an example of design
ooh spicy questions wrong question
yeah that's a good question well I don't
know it depends on how you look at it I
get people like that they hire me to use
the proposer sauce oh you broke up there
we wanted to hear the answer you know
design I think we're leaving is such a
good time for designers I would I would
say art our end design sometimes you can
because you can look at them when you
see them sometimes they're just like
letters and there are more designing and
sometimes you look at them and they're
just this you know were you looking at
but I guess I guess I'm gonna say art
art because I feel like we're leaving
the time where design is being innovated
and digital digital art is being
elevated to the point where you can make
it art you know I'm not saying all of
all of the things that I've done all my
designs are art but some of them arced
are art and some of them are not so
that's what I'm saying both but but if
you want to if you want to force me I'll
say art I don't know force you but our
audience does and I'm just just a vessel
for their opinion hey I want to make
sure cuz sometimes your audio is cutting
out can you quit any other background
application that you don't need open
right now just to make sure you guys
want to be able to hear every word you
say got you yeah there's any mail or
Spotify or anything that you don't need
to open just quit everything except for
zoom and Photoshop of course I almost
yeah we did they just did that is that
working now it's working I just
sometimes you cut out for whatever
reason you get that weird robot voice
mm-hm okay so we're good now yeah so far
so good yeah okay cool yeah so basically
I cut the arms the way I wanted them to
cut you know so it's kinda like they're
getting lost in there yeah a little bit
and why did you do that what what part
of your instincts tell you you need to
kind of put things in shadow crazy you
ask a lot of complicated questions I can
help you that's the question my mom used
to ask was like why do you paint these
this way I used to paint a lot when I
was a kid yeah I'm I feel it feels good
aesthetically that's good you know I
sort of feel like okay you know I didn't
like you know seeing I don't know this
hand it's a little thin standing out to
me right now so I'll probably do
something with it yeah but yeah I think
that's why okay I'll give you the art
school answer the art school answer is
it's a complicated image and he's trying
to reduce where you look at like as the
artist he's trying to direct her eye
towards his face and maybe parts of his
hand so by knocking everything else out
he's gonna say look at these parts these
parts feel important to me and by
reducing down the image and its
complexity he's able to help
the audience view or kind of look at
what he wants us to look at I love the
answer that's what you texted me just
right before the graze I'm gonna bring
you with me through every interview I
would be happy to be here time I do it
live and then I had to bring you
everywhere they asked me to do something
cuz I don't know how to do anything yeah
I love it
let's do it yeah yeah so basically what
Chris said yeah it'll be like what we
had just beyond here you used to be a
little rice little beans we together we
make something awesome I love it yeah
yeah so basically you know what it is
you know simplifying it like you said
Chris there you go
you know I'm changing now the the
grading in the back since I had it made
now usually don't do these but since I
added the blue I don't like this yellow
tones anymore mm-hmm I'm going more blue
with it
maybe something like this yeah I like
that
[Music]
yeah and I think you're following up
what you said I think that's why people
like my poster so much in the Instagram
it's because they they're easy to look
at when you see them on the small in the
small format right so you see them
they're like they're clean you can you
can look at them and they're not all
over the place and you know it's
different exciting for Instagram than
designing for for for other for other
things so if you mean if your main thing
is Instagram II you wanna like put your
work out there and use that tool I think
this is really important simplifying
things totally clean and aesthetically
pleasing yeah very good that's a great
tip designed for the medium in which
your aren't working to be viewed in most
and it's it's tiny it's like this little
little size since all that complex
detail it's confusing for the eye but
here's another reason why cuz my son is
getting into pain he's doing oil
paintings right now he's 16 years old
and at first he was trying his best to
do like realistic like Caravaggio style
painting he's not anywhere near that
good but that's what he was doing more
recently he started moving into more
abstraction and geometry it's not quite
cubism yet but it's getting closer and
closer and he feels really happy and I
think this is what's in
interesting is that the camera and the
photograph already do a great job of
capturing reality the artist says look
at the world through my eyes through my
lens and I'm gonna change reality a
little bit and I think that's another
reason why what you do is so interesting
and appealing yeah I love that and I'm a
huge fan of Delhi and I think that's
what he did to a lot of he merged
reality with with you know fiction in
the sense that you know it makes you
feel something it makes you look at
things that you normally see and make it
you know make you look at them
differently
so am i black and I think a lot of my
work also follows that kind of you know
surrealistic
feel you know I use a lot of realistic
images but I give it that twist as well
yeah so right now you know brightening
the unites maybe doing just kind of like
victory League to through the ice mm-hmm
again don't ask me why Chris I was just
about to ask you why let me read some of
the comments while you're working there
all right go for it
so okay obviously you're using Photoshop
here tell us a little bit more about
your computer setup with it what kind of
machine are you working on are using a
mouse a trackpad a Wacom tablet what are
you using
so right now I am using a PC mm-hmm
built that I see that I built this
pretty build I'm looking at it yeah yeah
yeah it's a custom builds pretty big and
I built this computer because trying
that I had while in a poster that was 20
feet by 60 feet at 3 not 600 dpi so even
to just he wanted a real sized what for
some reason yeah yeah and I that's what
I said I was like what are you sure and
they're like yes this is how we do it
they made it sound like that's the
normal stuff like that's how you do it
yeah but they're pretty they're pretty
kind so yeah
okay you know and when I bought the
computer because I knew I needed it also
for I've been getting into doing 3d kic
name before D mm-hmm
this is like super good for it it's City
some beefy video card in there yes I
have to RTX to any eighty how much of
those costs the Hulk I can tell you
price for the whole computer okay
that'll work
it's probably like forty nine hundred
okay not too bad too bad I thought you
gonna say $40,000 I'm like oh my god no
no no no okay okay no because I was
going to buy the same version of Mac
because it's what I what I used to use
the most yeah and he was gonna be like
around 40,000 mm-hmm so I was just
saying no I'm good with that
I'll build a PC so you betrayed the Mac
Triberr by Gooden PC and it was it's not
as bad as you think
yeah it's not it's really not it's much
worse I still do a lot of work on my on
my Mac because hey man we still love you
yeah even though you're living in Dallas
I'm getting hate everywhere yeah yeah so
yeah I switched I switched I'm sorry
guys I'm sorry everybody that's offense
okay I have a have a few friends that
are like super fans of like they can't
believe it's switched and blah blah
nobody man look we can't be friends
anymore
whatever works it's true it's never been
about the tool it's always the artist
but no yeah and also the software's are
the same you know what you think about
it for me and nothing has changed
honestly nothing must be you I have to
have to install so what do you call this
the I'm horrible so computers horrible I
have to install a little software thing
is all plugins on plugins um on PC all
the time but besides that everything
else it's pretty much the same right
I would think it was all right so you
have a custom-built PC with some bad boy
RTX video cards because you had an
assignment to do some really big poster
I'm assuming that they paid you enough
money where you're like yeah that's
justifies the cost right they did yes
did they pay me enough money to buy it
yeah and and also I wanted to
and already you know so it was a perfect
excuse with the wife also I got a mighty
sunny I'm sorry yeah I mean the client
said we have to do is 600dpi the size
even from here that's like pretty beefy
that was hard to handle yeah it was hard
to handle yeah you know so what do you
want it and are you working on a mouse
or a tablet or some other device right
now I'm working with the mouse and
working with the mouse yeah are you sure
to do trackpad though cuz honestly a lot
of these posters I was done with my Mac
yeah yeah I've done most of them would
my Mac and I use it I just used the
trackpad first I say so so yeah so I'm
still a Mac user yeah you know Orlando
auto Sina he does these amazing
illustrations using Adobe Illustrator
yet he is also using the trackpad I'm
like how are you guys creating this way
again it's a testament to your as skill
and what you're able to do within
constraints not having whatever it is
that everybody says they need to in
order to be good you just get good you
use what you have and you make the most
of it yeah let's do some excuse okay so
why is this gentleman crying white milk
talk to me about there wasn't a lot of
milk in Cuba I guess he cannot spare any
tears of milk then yeah he's you know
he's suffering for yeah no it looks good
from afar you see it's like pretty yeah
it's a little creepy yeah yeah I guess
you know your questions are being pretty
pretty creepy man so I'm like yeah what
can I say
yeah you do you have any you have any
more questions for me as long as you
know like my past and what I did and you
know I have a lot more questions for
sure so in with them it sounds to me
like you're self-taught correct yes
correct
okay and you you started learning
Photoshop when you were 13 by the time
you're at the ripe old age of 15 you're
a bona fide graphic designer getting
work and you guys
your whole family or just you moved from
from Cuba to United States well my whole
family moved I moved with my parents
first and then my brother came after and
we had a pretty pretty rough time
getting here because we were put in jail
in Mexico for three months and so that
was an experience but you know once we
got here it was fine okay
everything why'd you guys go to jail
because we were going through Mexico
illegally okay no yeah we're coming over
here so they they cut us down there at
the Border Patrol
by the border yeah Border Patrol in
Mexico caught us and and we went to jail
in Mexico City for three months and you
know that's that experience tends to
like my parents I was going my parents
and they we got split so we would see
each other every Thursday oh my god for
for 15 minutes and it was you know it
was it was pretty tough but at the same
time like everything else in life like
you look back at it and it's just like
you know it's a little more something
else another block to build see you know
basically and that's why I see it yeah
it was it was a good experience in the
bad experience the same time yeah for
sure yeah I want to highlight any circle
head yeah I want to have that quick
question here somebody's asking this
question the first job that you got is a
working professional designer creative
how much did you get paid what was it it
was it was doing the album arts the the
music studio Miami and I got paid
something like seven dollars an hour
okay and in your 15 I was 15 yes and
then I would do couple of jobs here and
there for people that wanted logos and
metal things for $100 and $150 stuff
like that mm-hmm
okay so you're you're put in jail for
three months I can't even imagine what
that must be like for a 15 year old kid
and just being separated and what was
your mindset like at that point in time
well again coming from Cuba like you
know I'm gonna be guys know any other
Cuban person or you know the story of
Cuba or
how Cuba is but it's a pretty you can't
have always the mindset of like just
doing whatever you have to do mm-hmm
there is no you know I have the option
to do this or do that it's more of a you
know I have to do this not do it so
basically I didn't have any partial cuts
when I was in there I was just going
through the motions I say and obviously
later on you know when you become an
adult you think back at Danny like that
was great right right but during during
the moment he was more of a I was just
going through the motions and I was just
leaving through the moment and it was
crazy times but yeah did your parents
say anything to you as they're kind of
tearing you guys apart and separating
you like what were the last words your
parents told you before you kind of got
separated well they said I mean
obviously yeah I can't just imagine
because now now I'm a dad I have a
two-year-old son yeah and I can just
imagine man how what they were going
through I think it was a lot tougher for
them than it was for me just having to
to go away you know but I they I can't
remember where they say I couldn't
remember the last thing they said but
they you know I remember the moment we
were there and they were taking because
they they would take off all of your it
didn't give us any clothes to wear like
prison clothes they just took away our
belt and our our sneakers the shoelaces
they took him away and anything that you
could use for violence made basically so
he took all of those away and hard you
know it was a tough moment they didn't
show any sign of like breaking down you
know my mom wasn't crying or anything
and but I remember like you know the
uncertainty of what was going on and we
knew we had to be there for a certain
time what they did like an investigation
on us to make sure we were really Cubans
because the the US government protected
us ASCII had to release us eventually so
we knew were getting out it was just you
know just uncertainty and that and that
day it was really high and but I can't
remember any specific words really
later on things got better inside you
know like the first week was bad because
you get nervous obviously and all that
then from there I started I started
making money because I was selling I was
like I drew a guard and the guard liked
me and then he he told me whatever you
want from outside I can bring you you
just gotta pay me the normal amount that
it costs and I'll bring it to you so I
you know I saw an opportunity and I you
started selling through the the people
in there oh my god
it wasn't hitting bad I was just selling
coca-cola and you know M&Ms and whatever
they wanted from outside like these
Mexican candies and stuff so ask them eh
what do you want they would tell me and
then I would tell the guard he will
bring it to me and I would charge three
pour or double depending if I like the
person and then I was just like making
money there you know it started hustling
yeah yeah these nuns would come on
Sunday and they would sing songs with us
and and then they would go see the women
because we were in different prisons you
know and I knew they were gonna see my
mom after and we normally send letters
to her moms or whatever and I would say
my mom letters and our chocolates and
money and my mom got super nervous and
you say what are you doing in there
what's going on do anything crazy you
don't get involved with coca-cola I want
you to meet everything is fine my god so
there's a lot to take away from this
story now I want to make sure I want to
make sure because I want to I want to
finish a poster before this is over so
we can guess it all and talk at the same
time yeah you keep working and then
we'll keep telling weird for how long do
we have how long do we have as long as
we need bad okay yeah just keep going
though okay yeah we finish this quickly
I want it to be worthy of your Instagram
post make sure it's legit now
here's what we've learned that art can
actually make prison life much easier
for you that's one key takeaway ladies
and gentlemen
art can help you if you find the right
prison dog who's got a little twinkle in
his eye and as appreciation for the Arts
he can help you now the other thing that
we need to know is where did you get the
seed capital because he's like I'll buy
it for you if you give me the money
where's this money well I thought they
strip you of all your stuff nor did
people have money there you could take
money inside you take money inside the
prison you could take money in this
prison here the nuns now the nuns would
bring stuff on Sundays but you had to
wait until Sunday okay you give them
money and they would bring you things
from outside that you want it I said but
but I didn't have any money at all
when I started right the guard told me
that and I was like man start ending
stuff and then so I would tell the
people hey here's days I'm trying to
find some pictures of stars right here
I'm getting interests and I want to
answer a quick question because we
talked about this before we went on air
in terms of where he gets images from he
says he mostly gets them from Adobe
stock which I assume then he's acquiring
them through legal means
and also unsplash right did you send
Smosh yeah yeah not a splash is legit
for you to use it's got a I think a
similar Creative Commons thing you could
use it you can modify it you could sell
it you could do whatever you want so
you're fine right and right now I just
told this one from from the internet but
yes as you say that you just stolen from
the Internet
yeah if you're saying that yeah I was
stealing yeah but this is just arsons
going in the background yeah I'm gonna
fade it a lot so I'm not taking my main
image from there yeah so I'm so confused
the story line doesn't quite make sense
you you have some money maybe we'd have
to get anything out because I didn't I
didn't I didn't have money okay so how'd
you get that first money or first bit of
cash so that you can buy your license
although with the having it what that
make sense no I sold I sold to people
without I sold it to people without
having any money like I told people hey
do you want something from outside oh I
see I see you're a broker she got this
guy's a shark Jonah the government and
people don't
so hey here's okay here's the last thing
while mag deal is doing this with mostly
legal images here's how you did it he's
like you know I have a connection
outside my friend I could connect you to
some high level candy and he's like
giving the money first and I'll gladly
bring it to you
then he takes that any scores over to
the security guard or the nun and says
here's the money
get me the stuff and then no it's not
the nun will do for free for everybody
security guard was an everyday thing so
if people wanted like a deck of cards or
whatever something unusual yeah or like
you know like no I want you know I want
this and people were in there for a long
time there was a guy from the states
that was there because he was a miner
and he ran over this lady in the street
oh no yeah so he was you know he was out
there in vacation and he left and we
were blind and it was like music a shady
story yeah it was so good the guy the
thing is that obviously you know that H
also I didn't know what was going on
yeah I bet you didn't know what was
going on yeah exactly so but he you know
he did have a couple boyfriend's in
there I have one one you have many yeah
because he had money so he's like yeah
so how we went from a very innocent
beautiful idyllic sir Pop's a real thing
until we're getting some dark things
this guy's like crying milk for a very
dark childhood that McNeil's lived
through but he didn't realize what he
was going through we've also learned
that it's a Cuban you're very resilient
you just adapt
whatever happens you just adapt there's
no time for tears or feeling bad yeah at
least that was the reality for me yeah
and in a lot of Cubans that I know so
yeah so basically that was that was the
season of my life and then I I got to
and I got to Miami and we had to pay we
owed a lot of money because we the money
that we used to come here
we ordered to people in the states in
the states you have friends in the
states we have family
okay okay family we have family Miami so
we say we oh you know a lot of our money
and
is it kind of familiar you have to pay
back so yeah you know guys there's two
kinds of family the one they're after me
and the ones you like who are you again
money yeah exactly so you know my mom we
most started taking jobs you know like
doing a stuff and like you know like we
would serve her parties and clean up
after things and go to you know work
places to clean after hours now go with
her after school and then I also got
that job and I was contributing a little
bit to the house you know helping out
and and then I moved to Texas I was
about to turn 18 I was at the end of
seven seventeen and I moved here by
myself
oh why Texas all places well you could
use is that even a question Chris
legitimate question why Texas is the
best Chris yeah so basically I had I had
a rough time when I got to the states
because of the way you know life is here
so that was the hardest part really it
wasn't like going to priests and all of
that it was more of a over a you know
you got to you get to States and it's a
different mentality
everybody's working all it's time you
don't see your friends every day you're
not hanging out with people all the time
you you you know you live here and you
you work more than anything else you
know yeah so that was a really hard and
different culture for me so I kind of
got you know kind of depressed about it
at about missing my friends cuz he was
really tough with communication there's
no internet in Cuba at that point what
there wasn't any eating eating it so I
would spend a lot of money also cutting
back my friends it was like a dollar and
sixty cents a minute yep to call back to
Cuba during that time and I was just sad
so so you know my dad my dad was a
pastor in and I always liked you know
you know the the missions and helping
people so I came to a mission school
here in Dallas that's why I moved to
Dallas okay basically to like I like I
was looking for something that would
help me get over that and change my life
from that sense of like not not being
chasing money all the time but having a
greater purpose you know that's why I
moved to Texas and this here's where I
met my wife and then I just stay here
because I loved it it's you're
definitely better than Miami in my
opinion I'm sorry what ethnicity is your
wife she's Mexican she's Mexican okay
from Mexico yeah I also didn't like
Mexican because because of what I went
through man is in prison exactly yeah
they store passwords because they sell
them in Mexico they pretend to be Givens
to get here it was a really tough
situation
oh my gosh and before we even got to
that big prison where they split us we
were in this letter one for three days
when they first got us and the whole
purpose of that one was to get money out
of us dang and they were they kept
saying like hey we're gonna we're gonna
you know we have a family already this
and adopt him here in Mexico you're not
gonna see your parents anymore and then
they would bring me in and say you know
we're killing your parents and it was
like super obviously you know like tough
you know
yeah and through the whole time we were
thinking man it's something bad is gonna
happen I we're just you know so you know
with that being said that's why I do you
know Mexicans at that time but then to
Texas there's so many Mexicans here and
I met some cool Mexicans and I made my
wife and I have a bunch of friends now
that are Mexican yeah it's you know
exchange of perspective actually you
know can you find everybody by just the
actions of a few people but that's why
well side beat in you know yeah at that
point at that point it's her sir laughs
and Moore's asking you a random Cuban
question here and he's like is it true
in Cuba because you guys didn't have
internet access that there were thumb
drives being passed around with bootleg
pirated copies of shows anything that's
real thing real thing you sell something
that's called it pockety yeah
which means the package and the package
you can buy it
custody two dollars a week I believe and
then you get all of the Internet in the
thumb drive basically I mean you bring
your hard drive and they dump a lot of
like news articles and shows from
Netflix um all of the updates that come
out on these shows and stuff like that
and you have it all for two dollars a
week and you you show up at these guys
house with with the thumb drive and you
download at all that's how it works
so does he have like a bootleg satellite
that he's able to get internet himself
ain't download everything he's connected
with people in Miami and they do it that
way I don't know all the details but I
think it includes like traveling
I think Vox vo X the YouTube channel did
a little whole thing on that I say so if
you want to see something like more
detail than me telling you wow it's
really yeah it's really intricate
business away
I love having conversations like this
because it allows me to see or at least
get a glimpse of the world that you were
living in mm-hmm you know it's like just
so shocking so as a Cuban are you
automatically deemed by the US as a
refugee that people who can escape Cuba
can come to the United States no problem
you used to before Houston took that you
know they got rid of that law a few
years back I thought you used to you
used to be able to use as soon as as
soon as you step yes mm-hmm
you are automatically accepted u.s. at
least as a resident you know and then
you have to apply for citizenship within
five years but you accepted because you
know it's kind of like the just kind of
like the thing you have to get here it
since that's why so many people go
through the sea and they try to escape
Cuba because they know if they make it
here that they're good yeah I say yeah
and there's a very you know the reason
why people do this it's a better feature
here you can do whatever you want here
basically you know if you say something
you can have it you can work hard for
different things that's not the case in
Cuba yeah yeah the private sector is not
a thing in Cuba yeah so it's really
tough to you know to have business make
money doctors make the same money that
any body makes I give
cleaning so it doesn't make sense you
know it's like ten dollars a month
mm-hmm yeah then you go to the store and
they cost you the same amount of money
that I cut see here for a piece of meat
and then red meat is illegal which is
crazy - Wow yeah that's a lot of stuff
general would that be able to survive in
Cuba I definitely wouldn't make it he's
too delicate yeah
and talking about the subject of like
you know you have to do what you got to
do it's like in Cuba we used to buy meat
illegally you know to eat meat and we
were always carry the meat through
because we will go to these rural places
and that's what we would get the meat
and they will always put it under me in
the car like under my seat because I you
know the back seat up and we have this
deborah lippmann all right and the back
seat up and you put it right there and
then we will get stopped by the police
and you know you have to act like
nothing's happening so you learn how to
do a [ __ ] like that from a young age the
the young criminal was born how did he
learn how to sell goods in prison well
it began with just meat sitting on a hot
piece of meat is what he did he's like
don't sweat man look him right in the
argument those dead eyes nothing nothing
yeah you even have to like tell them
what's up man you know like push back a
little bit of the culture okay getting
back to the work here I see that you've
turned our statuesque very fit black man
here into like a transparent person like
you could see through him yeah yeah
basically it's like you can see that was
behind them turns into vector basically
yep it was inside of him is like reality
but yeah that's what we got so far
mm-hmm see I want to delete it from on
top of these there you go yes I'm
writing some letters on top of these you
either let more texture make it more
interesting
now what's guiding your decision to add
a mountain
or to duplicate the mountain or to cut
it out of course I'm gonna ask you a
question it is gonna be difficult to
answer but that's my job
yeah so basically I want it I want to do
something it's too plain before like use
to without a mountain there's nothing in
it right yeah so I think with it is
giving it that extra a little something
that makes you look at it a little more
you know gives you that little second
second scoop at it like if you you're
the kind of person that you scroll
through the images you might miss it you
might see at the overall picture and
like it mm-hmm
but if you the person that you know
stare slightly a little longer there's
something more for you there it's for
you to see you know that's basically I'm
just going with the flow here man I'm
talking and you know I'm really not
thinking through this at all I'm just
I'm just going with it and that's one of
the things that I that I feel like you
know like people ask me all the time how
do you say creative to do things you
know all the time and all that and I
think it's like there's three three
rules to that okay the first the first
rule is to to stay inspired by other
people basically you know look at a lot
of stuff spend a lot of time designing
your band in your mind without even
being in the computer you know spend
whole time looking at things the other
people make and also things that you see
on the street and how you can make it
better and then why do you think they
work and they don't work and the second
thing would be to to practice to do this
everyday to sharpen the tools so when
somebody asks you to do something like
this on the spot you have the tools
enough you know you've done this enough
times that you know okay a mountain
we're working here or circle will work
in the back you know I can just add it
and that's it it works because I've done
so many times that I know it works you
know
yeah and the third thing is this passion
you know like whatever your passion is
to do this to do what you do like
there's some work and kind of work that
I do that it's more passion than then
work for me and and no matter what
happens and how many times I do it I
always feel passionate about it so that
gives me that drive to keep going for
some people there's money for some
people is you know
motivation to be the best competition
whatever you want it to be but that
third thing would be you know the
passion the vision and the drive today
so if you have those three things you're
never gonna fail because whenever
whenever you don't feel inspired you
look at what other people are doing and
you that you might get an idea from that
whenever you don't feel like looking
what other people are doing you have a
ton of stuff that you usually do that
work then you know you know composition
you know colors and you can just do it
without even having to look at anything
whenever those two fail you have the
passion on the drive to keep chasing it
you know and that's why I feel like I
can stay inspire all the time to do
things and sometimes you know that fails
to like the thing of you know like
sometimes you don't want to do it
because you don't feel like doing it
you're in a different mood or whatever
but those seem to work all the time
because it's three different things and
they're all different and you can just
pull from the bagging and taking him you
know yep now I'm gonna give you the
art-school answer to his question as
well okay give me with that
here's article question is the high
loves contrast so initially he had a
very complicated image he made it
simpler but he kept the details because
otherwise it looked like a
two-dimensional cutout so the hands and
the head give you that detail and the in
the image was too photographic so then
he he kind of vectorized the eyes and
the tears so that there's this two
dimensional quality on top of a three
dimensional image he's always pushing
and pulling against extremes and then
now this is becomes a big shape so
adding the mountains takes big abstract
things and and also adds details so the
to really push against each other and
this is what he's doing he's pushing and
pulling the whole time now I noticed
that in the evolution of this one poster
that he's designing sometimes the giant
circle or the halo behind the man's head
is there and sometimes he moves it away
but I think he uses it as a
compositional element because it really
creates a lot of contrast between the
complicated irregular organic shape of
the head versus the super simple
geometric shape of the moon the Sun or
the halo the Christ image or whatever
he's creating there so so he's always
playing around with this and as
we've done many times before in our show
on typography when you introduce one
element it influences the other element
so he's constantly pushing and pulling
things until he feels like they're in
balance with each other so let's keep
looking at this so the next question for
you mag deal is how do you know when
this is done you can literally go on
forever yes but you know you know it's
the point where you're like okay I feel
like this this is balanced enough yeah
and basically that's the answer for me
the balance if you have good balance and
that's how I usually end up adding a
couple things here and there and moving
them like big elements like this you
know like this thing that I just add on
top yep or I'm gonna move this a little
bit to the point where I feel like it
looks good and I like it and then after
that doing some color adjustments and
we're done okay so if you feel like
there's still something that's not quite
balanced yet and once you nail that then
you'll do some final color tweaks yeah
exactly like you know this is looking
okay maybe we need some color right here
on the bottom left which I'm going to do
right now and that's why I make it small
like I make the image really small
sometimes I look at it because it makes
me makes me see the balance really well
you know you can already see like if you
make it as it's empty down here yeah
this also feels something you need
something on top I say good good trick
there yeah so you make a small screen
your eyes a little bit mm-hmm and then
you're good to go the old squint I test
guys it works every single time he does
even for non-asians it works guys now
yeah I must have not been paying
attention but you created these graphic
shapes in the back these the extension
of the mountain did you take the mask
and paint inside of it or said something
else no I I grabbed these this mountain
and I pentool it around it yeah and then
after I have the pen tool I have just
duplicated because I have the mountain
and also the pen - yeah and then you
paint it inside of it the pen or made a
selection and made a selection and is
off into the brush yeah yeah exactly
that's what I did nice now you have a
lot of warm and cool colors here you got
the old teal and orange plaid going yeah
do you feel like you
you want to balance the colors the
temperatures in your composition so you
just go with the flow yeah I'll probably
do that at the end yeah said I I apply
like a color correction over the whole
thing at the end mm-hmm and that helps
it all bring it all together nice you'll
see what I mean the second okay I trust
you yeah over here I'm just caleb saying
this room is so good
instant like on the video which reminds
me everybody that's watching all 300 you
guys please do us a big solid and hit
the thumbs up if you are enjoying this
video if you're enjoying the dark dive
into surrealist kind of history of
mcgill time in prison selling candy do
what she's got to do to survive on the
mean streets of Mexico I think it was a
mistake tell the story that's how you
know it's a good story when you regret
telling it I'm going to be not maybe
what we gotta do is get right grants and
to make a a free Mac deal from prison
poster do you know we'll return the
favor that could be kind of cool it's
like hey man I was again with the
precent right yeah yeah those tears are
for the people he killed in prison in
case you're tuning in midway through the
stream he's a good Christian man he's
married he has a child he's working hard
for for forever at learning Photoshop at
an early age putting food on the table
for everybody he cares about we're
talking to Magda Lopez if you guys want
to check them out his website is Magda
elope ello P and calm and you could
follow them also on Instagram where he's
been able to grow his very small
following from 400 people to 20,000 in a
matter of weeks or days or something
like that based on doing this wonderful
series and it's the reward of doing
something consistently as you become
very proficient at it you start to do
things intuitively which is kind of
where he's at right now and it's been
able to open doors for him with
collaborations and projects with some of
the biggest fortune 100 companies and
world yeah it does a better version of
me Chris thank you
like I said I'm available for speaking
engagements let me know Meghalaya we
could be a part of a two-man act here
you make the art I'll try to make people
laugh no guarantee answer let me go back
to a professional career reality okay
yes I worked I worked for a long time
doing graphic signs and then when I
decided to post stuff online due to
mostly friends that were like man you
need to start posting stuff we love for
you do blah blah and then I started
posting and you know within the first
100 posters it went up to like 20,000
people that they were following you know
my Instagram page and then when I was
done with the project I was at around
60,000 and it just kept growing from
there I'm close to 90 right now and it's
just because of this you know I just
post once a day and I'm horrible at
keeping up with you know other people do
their things here and there and then
yeah you know interact more with the
audience and I try to do it but you know
I also have so much more going on and
also have a baby and you know I'm trying
to be good everywhere yeah and not kill
people like in prison you know you
actually look like a very sweet
gentleman you really do yes I am I scar
on Chris yes you have to do what you got
to do yeah yeah all right so this is I
mean we can add more stuff we can keep
going at it you tell me what you want to
stop I got some flowers here lots of
flowers let's do it I like how you mix
in the organic botanical stuff so I saw
that video you did on the dhobi
livestream and just adding that flower
creeping behind the guy's face when you
split them open was just a tree being
weird and beautiful at the same time I
love it I have a lot of flowers so what
I started doing is that you know when I
went to the adobe life they told me a
man why don't you instead of like
cutting the flowers every time what
which I used to do why don't you start
adding them to your library and then
every time you need and you just drag
them and drop them right there they're
done they're ready to go the dhobi team
yes they saw me struggling and like I'm
like man you know I'm cutting these
flowers every time and I don't need to
go Ruby yeah I have right now a few that
I can use bring in and add like this and
I don't think this one even works but
we'll see we'll see what it takes us
yeah you know what I'm always blown away
by and impress is the Adobe team they
really know their software inside and
out they know all these crazy keyboard
shortcuts and techniques that'll save
you hours off of your life yeah and it's
it's always fascinating to for me then
to see them bringing in artists and
designers to do their work and I'm even
watching like dude just hit that button
and go much faster if you do that but
then I can't make the artwork so you
could have all the shortcuts and all the
tools in the world and know everything
inside out and be a very good technician
and you can also be the worst Photoshop
user and make beautiful art ideally it
would probably be a mixture of the two
where you can make amazing art but you
know the tool so you're super efficient
yes yes but I would take the art over
the technician any day but that's just
me yeah but it's tough because when you
I mean when you spend a lot of time
doing art stuff it means that you know
you haven't spent a lot of time learning
stuff it just means you spend a lot of
time he's creating you know yes and then
the other way around too so it's tough
to have them both you know that's why
when I when I meet people I've gone gone
to school for design you know I it's
different it's a different feel you know
they do more by the book and things the
right way and spend a lot of time
picking fun oh no we lost you cut up
just do it
and hello okay we're back we're back
okay something is freaked out for a
second okay okay we're good I don't know
where okay so I was saying that when
they meet people that go for design yeah
sometimes you know I'm like man just do
it you know like done that space how
much time like thinking about it cuz I
feel like you're you can overthink
things when you know too much yes you
know versus when you don't know enough
you're more of a you know you're
innocent in the sensing like you're like
just go for it you know I like that the
flower you just added yeah is that it
working what is that
buddy's orchid right I don't know I
don't know why flowers but I like that
that leaf with the thing sticking out of
it is really cool so so geometric yes
yeah I don't know exactly what this is
but I like it too yeah
so let me here's the quote for Twitter
guys when you're busy doing a lot of art
stuff you don't have a lot of time to
learn stuff because you're busy creating
stuff there you go that's what Magda
said it's good stuff on this live stream
guys good stuff if you if you word it if
you word it a little better for me Chris
maybe we can make it work I'll make it
work I'll do the intro for your next
book thank you I love it alright so a
couple flowers in there
now we're off violence to the right or
the left yeah so I use the Sun like you
said a lot for you know filling up with
balance the places that I need you know
yeah like over here is really busy and
then you know left and right side with
this yeah and I got rid of my stars if
we got a bottom there you go where are
they and then already Adams okay yeah
and you know I use a circle then to
filling just those parts and they can
feel a little better
mm-hm and you know you can always come
back here and you change this again like
if you don't feel like I feel like now
contrast is out the window a little bit
with everything being so so purple and
kind of like blue oh you can change your
backing if we need to mm-hmm wanna be a
couple quick comments here from Mirza
saying I love this stream man sending
love from Singapore reverse cuts
I'm loving this live stream no hate but
way more loose than Adobe lifes he did
two months ago
well I'm glad because we're not Adobe
live guys we're the future we do things
differently we sprinkle a little humor
in and some personal stories in there
and hopefully we all have a different
perspective than just seeing a person
work yeah
no hate stories yeah okay Lenny Ramirez
is that you know this video will rank
for Cuban Paquette bucket a bucket they
okay yes yeah all right
what else are we doing here okay so this
is very interesting it almost can be
like this surreal stamp that you're
designing for Saturn mmm you know some
other place some outer world thing where
there's plants and people live in
harmony and there's giant sized things
in the background or buildings in the
future are made to look more botanical
and there's this gentleman he's a he's a
warrior poet philosopher and he's got
these giant like african-inspired rings
around its neck and he's just meditating
or something I love it we just need the
price of a stamp and we're ready to fly
to Saturn yeah yes sir okay so are you
doing some final I just noticed you just
did a color correction there or
something
yeah cooler tone good my dude you gotta
walk through this don't slip in the
secrets right there and no I'm changing
a little bit the color of this one yes I
didn't even like that much yeah I'll do
it again so some color balance you know
yeah to make it a little bit different
yeah I think if it fit in a little bit
better right it was two contrasting
before maybe he was too conscious cue
this one you see his pops out too much
yeah so I'm probably doing the same
thing with this one yeah you cooled this
guy down you took some of the yellow out
you shifted the hue to this kind of
pinkish lavender purple yeah yeah and
now I'm like contrasting a little bit
more okay not taking some contours out
of the flower in the back for it to fit
more fitting more with the whole thing
yeah and then at the end I usually go up
all the way up and that add color
balance on top of everything so you're
adding a color adjustment layer yeah and
that really gives you you know over the
whole image it brings it all together
yeah cuz now you can add a lot of blue
or a lot of red
and affects everything so I like doing
this towards the end as well yes that
makes a lot brighter but also like
yellowish and then I'm probably gonna
also add a hue/saturation and bump up
the saturation a tiny bit or a lot
actually yeah yeah so that's a
compositing trick that everybody that
does compositing knows by creating an
adjustment layer color correction layer
over everything you unify the colors you
bring them together and you kind of
smash them together while being
non-destructive so this is like a trick
that good compositors know yep nice and
that's you know that's basically the
last step to do these okay can we do
this can we blacken out the screen go
fullscreen with this graphic and just
zoom in a little bit tighter so we can
see it it's glory there it is so we went
from nothing not even knowing what
subject Magda was gonna pick and he just
found a random image he found a guy and
he just created this composition out of
thin air within the time span of a
little over an hour and all the while
telling his dark past his his time in
prison the hard years hustling at a 15
year old just doing what it takes to
make it in the world of design now I
want to jump forward I'll talk a little
professional stuff for you okay do it
now you're no longer working for $7.00
an hour now I don't want to get into
anything that's super sensitive for you
but give us an idea of like how much
does it cost if somebody's watching is
if some company you haven't worked with
before sees this and we need to have you
for our next beverage campaign to make a
single image how much does it cost to
start talking to you and how do you
structure your fees can you give us some
ideas yeah so I mean basically you want
to you want to gather as much
information from the client you know how
much money they have so that changes
everything
so because sometimes you know clients
are smaller and they're really really
doing some small event let's say they're
doing an event that's only 300 people
200 people or whatever right so you
don't you don't you know you don't
necessarily want to go crazy with budget
when it comes to that
but if you have a client that you know
they're spending millions of dollars
putting your image all over a CD then
you can you know you deserve to make
more money if that makes sense you know
they're using more eyes my eyeballs go
on that and that's helping sell product
so you want to have you if you're not
good at doing that yourself you need to
hire somebody that that's good at
researching annoying and asking
questions and getting answers you know
yeah so you know I don't know if you
wanted me to go any more specific than
that but basically that's it you have to
you have to do your research to know how
much money the company has yeah and how
big of a deal this image is within the
scope of this whole thing yes so a good
no what I'm saying is that usually big
companies they they already have a
budget set up and they already tell you
this how much we would want to pay you
for these because they know it's worth a
lot more money so you should even people
tell you we want to give you $4,000 for
this it's because they know it's worth
12 you know and and they only want to
pay for you should want to tell you the
budget right away before you even start
talking the reason is because they have
a lot more money you can get a lot more
money and you deserve a lot more money
because a lot of money's being spent on
this campaign so you know it's a thing
of experience you have to do a lot of
talking with clients and knowing and
there's a few things that can indicate
that you know but like like that like
that's that's one of them the client
telling you hey we have four thousand
dollars to do this this is what we need
versus the client saying hey we we got
this campaign you know there's more
wiggle room if you if you got if you
have if you can negotiate but usually
the big big sharks they hit you with
already a budget so you cannot you know
you don't want to do it or not basically
yep since yeah it makes sense now if I
say something that you feel like don't
say that Chris just they don't say that
I'm gonna abstract the details here but
as you're sharing or store
before we went on air you and a friend
we're talking about a large kind of
beverage company won't even say who and
the friend was saying to you I do we can
get a lot more for this than what you
think and you're like no I don't know
that's a lot of money and can they do
that
so you had somebody who was not shy
about asking for money and you went from
maybe thinking about a few thousand
dollars per image to fifteen thousand
dollars per image for a total three
images right yeah also the very
beginning of my you know I was doing a
lot of posters and Instagram started
growing and yeah I started getting a lot
of messages from brands and you know
they told me we want these three images
to go on a campaign and and up to that
point I think this spends the most of
guiding was four thousand dollars for
for an image which was to meet
mind-blowing right and it is a lot of
money especially in other parts of the
world but at the same time it's not
enough for for some of the money to get
spent on these campaigns so my friend he
was like you know he's a big friend of
me he was helping me answer a lot of the
emails and he was you know I was paying
him chin like a percentage and he was
like man we have to ask for a lot of
money because these people got money and
I was like hey I'm not sure I don't know
man I got I don't know I've never asked
for that much money who's like yeah
let's ask for fifteen thousand for image
there one two three images and I was to
say man I don't know I I I don't I mean
I don't mind losing it let's I mean I do
mind loosing it but I wouldn't mind
losing it for for the right reason you
know like we asked for a lot more let's
at least hear what they say right he
convinced me to do it and then they
ended up going for twelve thousand so
they paid for it basically and then
later on whenever they paid us and use
the whole process of making these things
do you know how this takes times and and
we went through the whole process and
after that they sent me an email and I
think they by mistake send me an image
of the image that I made and attached to
the image was the the spending code for
the space advertisement space in the
city they were advertising this product
on and it was 4.5 million well
though they were spending 4.5 million
putting it all over the city and they
pay me 15 for 12,000 per image so at the
end of the day but you even think about
it it's that ye I probably should have
got him more money that make sense yeah
and you know I didn't know at that point
he was like pushing me to like to be
more bold and I understand no but not
everybody's in that position you know
like I'm not saying like everybody's in
the position of doing that but if you do
get approached by that by a big brand
and you do have the opportunity to work
for somebody like that you should
definitely either look for some
counseling from for people that are like
already doing that or or you should you
know do some research on what you should
get for stuff like that absolutely thank
you for sharing that story and for what
you told us before off-air was that was
an eye-opening experience for you that
at first you're like ah that's a lot of
money I just don't know it's what a lot
of designers and creatives do we talk
ourselves down we're like it's not that
hard I could do this and I don't want to
lose this job this is a good stepping
stone for my career and to be able to
have that client that brand to say I
worked with them that was going to be a
big move for you but luckily your friend
I hope he learned this from watching us
or something like that and he's like now
Magda we got to go for it and he
convinced you and you have the courage
to like okay let's try because
regardless if what happened was if they
spent four and a half million dollars
for the media Buy which is what that
budget the accident sent you you would
have been kicking yourself in the in the
butt really hard by saying oh we only
charge $3,000 per image and this is what
happens the more sophisticated media
buyers that are used to kind of just
grinding on artists like us they know
how to talk us down we should not help
them talk us down we should try to float
a number that's big relative to the size
of a campaign and the brand and then see
what they say because if they really
want you here's my philosophy on this if
a client really wants to work with you
money will not be an issue I don't mean
that they will pay you just about
anything but if it's the wrong number
they'll either coach you up or coach you
down so that you could get the job
because they really just want to work
with you because there's only there's
only one of you out there that's it
Yeah right right so yeah and that's he
was a huge fan of your of your podcast
and he he he was like man look at Chris
saying over here and you know it's such
a is the beginning of me doing this kind
of stuff so I was just like man I don't
know and you say trust me bro
trust me bro and then you're like and
you end up recent yes
so you can also think about this at the
word that Mac deals thinking about is
it's called impressions how many
impressions are being made of your image
or how many impressions are going to be
shared for example the the friend that
is asking for a small concert or
gathering maybe 300 people will come
there it's a one-day event so the
maximum value to that person is 300
people if there are big ticket people
and he's trying to sell a ten billion
dollar building well it's worth a lot
but take that in consideration whereas
if it's being printed on Billboard's
magazines it's being shared on TV and on
the web on social media that's a lot of
impressions and if you amortize the
costs across each compression it's very
little money
segi Aviv had said this before he's like
how long do you want your logo to live
for and when they say 30 years you say
just take our bill and divide it by 30
and it's a very small number yeah that's
how you kind of look at it and that's
yeah super smart and and do you think do
you think there's any push tannish
because I we you know working with
especially people in the film industry
and and TV shows do you feel the dursa
percentage of even the product that you
should consider when you're making the
design do you have any formula like that
there's no hard fast formula because
each and every every situation is
different but what you do need to know
is this and for all the artists and
designers out there in the world who are
uncomfortable talking about money have
no idea when you say research like that
what is what does it even mean you need
to talk to somebody who's more business
savvy than you to at least consult them
you could pay them an hourly fee you can
give them a percentage of the value that
they get over a certain percentage so if
you you're going in there thinking the
maximal forget is 10,000 then they say
we can get you 80,000 then do a deal
with them let them deal with the hard
and get on the phone and negotiate for
you because what they have what you
don't have is objectivity see it's you
it's your work you're so close that you
can't see it you can't see the magic of
what you do get something like that they
can just sit there like this is a
business transaction you have something
that they want they have something that
you want you have art they have money
and they'll make it work for you but you
guys when you're doing packages and
things that get printed over and over
you're probably gonna want to do a
limited license licensing deal and so if
they want exclusivity and if they want
to buy out those things cost even more
so here's a quick rule of thumb and I
think we're need to wrap up the show
here here's the quick rule of thumb take
your base price whatever you think it is
and I would say at least double that
because you're already going to estimate
really low and then for everything that
they ask a lot of impressions if they
ask for exclusivity if they want to do a
buyout keep multiplying that price until
you get up there and be confident say
your price and just be quiet and see
what they say yeah that was does being a
game changer for me it's surrounding
myself with people that are like more
business savvy and they they they know
that you know they're into that sensing
they are into that that kind of like
world of like this is a business
transaction it's not about you know what
this is or it's not it's just about
money you know at the end of the day
just money and yeah and they do that
side and I you know I you know I give
them that side because I'm not by you
know by paying somebody ten percent or
50 percent whatever their fee is I'm
going to make more money at the end
because they're gonna be able to bring
more money in than I am by myself and
you know I've heard 6 percent and I've
heard whatever percent you know I'm
making on products or whatever but at
the end a like you said it's like a
matter of like what the product is what
the client is and what the money they
have you know they're gonna spend on the
campaign yeah okay
Nigel thank you very much you're a
lovely human being despite a very kind
of rough start in the beginning of your
life especially the time in prison three
hard months that you've done peddling
candy to prison inmates and whatever
else you had to do to survive
total respect you and your your
resilience that's spirit and this is why
I think America is such a great place
because we are a country of
of immigrants and in each immigrant kind
of population brings a different energy
different culture and I'm I for one and
we're just glad to have you here glad to
have you on the show too so ladies and
gentlemen this is Magda Lopez this is
how you guys get in touch with them it's
Magda Lopez comm and Magda lop I think
did I do that right or is it Magdala
that's fine they're both thinking the
same place no take you the same place
okay thank you very much and I hope you
have a great day is your post is your
Instagram posts is this is the image you
made ready for your post or do you need
to make more adjustments to it before
you're ready to share I'll post a post
like this tomorrow really so it's like
it's ready to go you have to you have to
make it an hour if you don't make it an
hour yeah do it for long it's true you
take 12 hours to do it if you don't
right yeah okay all right that's it I
wanna thank everybody for joining us
live guys we'll see you tomorrow I think
we have a couple more live streams or
we're doing all kinds of crazy stuff
here
thanks very much for tuning in don't
forget to Like comment and subscribe
guys ring that bell for notifications
you know we're on our 1 billion mission
the hat that I'm wearing today that that
I'm wearing today it's the one be minus
1 1 billion minus one go check that out
Raul is making this hat see you guys
later thanks for being part of the
donation piece